rio de janeiro with its harbor like a
fallen star
and the curve of its beaches with their
names like songs
flamingo votofogo copacabana rio
isn't what it was these days
it's a city emblematic of a country in
trouble
there are signs of corruption everywhere
from the football stadium rebuilt for
the world cup with dirty money
to the bay choked with pollution because
corrupt officials never cleaned it
then there's the violence last month 28
was shot dead by the city's police
in the bloodiest favela raid in rio's
history
and to top it off the city's hospitals
are struggling to cope with covert 19.
this is just one city in a country of
more than 211
million people but the problems it faces
are felt nationwide i think it's going
to be a really
complicated and tense couple of years
with something that the whole world
should be paying attention to
despite all this thousands of brazilians
were on the street last month
to show their support for right-wing
president jair bolsonaro
a former army captain famous for his
racist
sexist and homophobic comments
his actions are now threatening not only
brazilian democracy
but one of the world's most important
natural resources
so why are his followers still so
faithful
and could the country withstand another
four years of his leadership
coronavirus has taken a terrible toll on
brazil
in april the country suffered the
highest rate of covert deaths
of any nation on earth and many blame
president jaye bolsonaro
for letting it get this bad
he famously dismissed the virus as
nothing more than flu
that wouldn't affect a strong man like
him
and as hospitals ran out of oxygen he
refused to order lockdowns
and even joked the vaccine could turn
people into crocodiles
bolsonaro's early response to the covid
crisis
was to shrug it off to say that
you know covert wasn't a big deal and of
course that hasn't proved
to be true and covid has killed one in
every 500 brazilians
the number is absolutely catastrophic
despite this in the early months of the
pandemic
bolsonaro's popularity soared this was
because his government issued emergency
payments
to keep people out of poverty it was one
of the biggest welfare programs in
brazil's history
without it the number of people living
on the breadline
would have more than doubled whereas by
the end of 2020
a million people had been lifted out of
poverty
these policies led to almost god-like
worship of bolsonaro
among some people
this is bahaji pajuka a town es salvador
in the northeast of brazil it's one of
the poorest parts of the country
with the highest rates of unemployment
but that doesn't matter to senor antonio
his family runs the town fish store and
he is a local politician
and passionate bolsonaro supporters
do you want to
is just one of the tens of millions of
brazilians who voted for bolsonaro in
2018
when he was elected with 55 percent of
the vote
but just 10 years ago it would have been
unthinkable
that someone like bolsonaro would take
power here
brazil was riding high the country was
led by a progressive government
headed by a woman jilma hussefi
it was slated to host the upcoming world
cup and olympics
and touted as a future economic
powerhouse alongside the other brics
economies
russia india china and south africa
the economy was booming over the course
of 2010
gdp grew by 7.5 percent and poverty was
falling
but then things started to change in
2014
the country fell into a deep and lasting
recession
partly caused by the end of the
commodities boom and financial
mismanagement
by ms husefi's workers party
the main consequence of the economic
crisis was uh
this uh perception this increased
perception that the political class was
um
inefficient and and didn't have the
capacity to deal
with those problems alongside this
the workers party or pt was engulfed in
a huge corruption scandal
known as lavagiato or car wash after the
petrol station where it was first
uncovered
you know it wasn't a huge surprise to
people that there was corruption going
on but what was
a massive shock was the scale of it
dozens of companies were bribing the
state oil firm
petrobras to get government contracts
and that that money was then being
funneled to
all sorts of different political parties
into this
came bolsonaro a little-known
congressman who made much of his
military credentials as a former army
captain
he promised to bring back order to the
corrupt system
what elected him in the end wasn't so
much the policies that he promised
but really this rebellion against what
had been there before him
we are
bolsonaro also borrowed heavily from
donald trump's playbook
[Applause]
like trump he used social media to rally
support
and position himself as a plain speaking
man of the people
even if his views were deeply offensive
[Music]
he appealed to conservative voters by
promising to restore family values
and key to his election success were
evangelical churches
brazil is the world's largest catholic
country
but evangelical protestantism is
predicted to become the biggest religion
here
in just over 10 years time
back in bahaji worshipers at one local
church are among the many evangelicals
who voted for him cremilde
and has been a member of the church
since she was 7.
and she was proud to vote for bolsonaro
as a man of faith
but now he's been in power for a few
years kumilda is starting to question if
bolsonaro is the best man to lead brazil
is not alone in her assessment in recent
months
bolsonaro's popularity rating has
dropped to below 30 percent
the lowest since he came to power
this is partly because the economic aid
in the early days of the pandemic
has now dried up and the reality of
brazil's economic situation
is setting in despite gdp recovering
more strongly than expected
unemployment has hit an 18-year high and
now that the government payments have
stopped
the poverty rate is higher than it has
been for over a decade
but bolsonaro shows little enthusiasm
for the kind of interventions needed
to get the economy back on track
so in bolsonaro's first year in office
they did manage to do
a really important pensions reform but
then after that the other reforms sort
of stalled
he was done doing unpopular economic
proposals
and um and so you know this whole
economic agenda
really just stayed on the table
but bolsonaro's policy decisions do not
just affect brazil
some have a bearing on the welfare of
the entire planet
brazil is home to the amazon rainforest
and although deforestation in the amazon
had been rising since 2012
it shot up when he took office
a lot of the damage that has been done
it's irreparable
he cut the budget of the environmental
ministry
he you know forced out a lot of the most
competent staff
and then he also sent a really um
you know a really powerful message to
people who are involved in deforestation
which was that
it's okay with me and the the effect of
that has just been catastrophic
his record on corruption is equally dire
[Music]
two of his sons are being investigated
for corruption
this has led him to abandon
anti-corruption reforms
and make deals with parties tainted by
the lava jato scandal
in the hope this will save his sons from
prison and himself
from impeachment the question is is this
damage that can be
that can be repairable is this you know
the kind of a
situation that someone else can come in
and sort of
fix what he has broken
and i think that this is really the main
question going forward
brazil's democracy is still young and
there are positive signs that it will
survive bolsonaro
the country's institutions have managed
to hold him in check
congress and the supreme court have
blocked some of his more extreme
proposals
such as allowing gun-owning brazilians
to openly carry firearms
and the pandemic has left him looking
particularly vulnerable
congress is now investigating his
handling of covert 19
which could hurt bolsonaro in the next
election and people are on the streets
calling for his impeachment
i don't think bolsonaro is going to be
able to
to undermine democratic institutions in
the country because what we've been
observing is that he
as he attacks democracy and and
and and opposes democratic institutions
he also
he's getting progressively more isolated
he's having a really hard time
governing bolsonaro has tried to shore
up his power through the military
but they may soon have to choose between
him and democracy
the next election in 2022 promises to be
a political showdown
as luis inacio lula da silva or lula
the most popular brazilian president to
date has hinted he will run again
but bolsonaro has already indicated that
should he lose the election
he would not go quietly and the events
that played out on capitol hill earlier
this year
could be repeated in brazil when you ask
could what happened in the u.s at the
capitol building happen in brazil
i think the answer is absolutely and
what we don't know is whether it would
turn out the same way whether in the end
the democratic institutions would be
able to sort of take control
so while brazil has so far survived
bolsonaro's onslaught
the greatest challenge to its democracy
may well be yet to come
and those on the ground are simply
praying that things will get better
his legacy is going to be you know a
tragic one
i hope that it's one that brazil can
recover from
that you know brazilian institutions can
start to pick up
the pieces and and heal from this i
think
they will but i think it's going to be a
really
complicated and tense couple of years
and you know it's something that the
whole world should be paying attention
to
[Music]
hi i'm sarah maslin i am the brazil
correspondent for the economist
if you would like to learn more about
brazil under zaire bolsonaro
please click the link to my special
report
and don't forget to subscribe